[Music]
so chuck i never give you a chance to
ask me a question for one of our
explainers anything been eating you
lately
well i mean since since you asked how
about because this is something you hear
all the time
especially in jokes believe it or not
really sh yeah schrodinger's cat wait
you have a quantum division of the joke
department well i don't think that the
comedians know what schrodinger's cat is
but it's such a
uh it's such a ubiquitous reference yeah
that they make reference to it a lot of
times
it's intercultural it's interesting it
has interculture i don't know why they
don't call it schrodinger's dog
okay
all right so
all right so it dates back to irwin
schrodinger
uh who irin yes and he was a physicist
right they're all one nobel prize is all
these people who contributed to our
understanding of the quantum right
and
quantum mechanics is what it's
officially called but i like just
calling it quantum physics because it's
an entire branch of physics that deals
with the small small things in the
universe uh all that so you do sweat the
small stuff yes you do
i see
precisely
precisely and uh the
schrodinger's cat relates a little bit
to what people have called the observer
effect
okay where if you observe something you
change it so i can respond to both of
those in the same
in the same pop if you allow me okay so
let's do the observer effect for the
moment so it's unfortunate that somebody
called it the observer effect because
then new age folk and other people who
were basically scientifically illiterate
were thinking it's your consciousness
that affects what you're
observing and oh my gosh there's a
consciousness field and they go running
off in a you know off the cliff see what
you don't understand is that like
particles
are totally alive
okay
and the reason why there is a collective
consciousness in the universe is because
like all of these particles that are
spinning what they're actually doing is
conducting thought and consciousness
they're thinking they're things they're
thinking man
rocks think trees think
more than rocks right so let me let me
cut through all of that and simply say
that you're sitting there and i can see
you
because in fact you're illuminated by if
not sunlight through an open window
an uncurtained window but artificial
light within the room all right that
light hits your face bounces off your
face goes through the computing system
and i see you okay
that light carries energy
every photon of light that strikes your
face carries energy
and then they they most of them reflect
others uh get absorbed actually depends
on how dark your skin is it's getting
very dark it'll absorb most of them if
you have that because you know
photons they want to be a part of this
baby
let me give something
let me give you guys
i see where we're landing
[Laughter]
yes just to be more precise about
chuck's excursion there uh darker
skinned people absorb more sunlight than
lighter skinned people and it's your
albedo
it's a it's the percentage of
incident energy that you absorb relative
to what you reflect very important
calculation for the earth because what
earth absorbs drives our climate whereas
what earth reflects back to space just
goes back to space
from the sun and so glaciers reflect
light cloud tops reflect light oceans
reflect light that sort of thing so for
climate change to solve it we just need
to get a bunch of white people in one
place
just reflect the light to reduce the do
us a favor guys
sunbathe everybody just sunbathe right
here reflect out the sun
okay
all right i'm sorry
i had to do it man all right don't write
don't write don't write but it was good
that was that was funny yeah that was a
good one yeah i mean if you if the earth
is getting hot you just just um increase
its albedo to increase the reflectance
of it so right yeah so uh instead of
chuck's solution everyone could just
wear white clothing and that would sure
even better right that's
[Laughter]
so
so
here's the thing if i made you tinier
and tinier and tinier right so you're no
longer a macroscopic human you're a
microscopic particle
there's a particle size below which
when you open the curtains and shine
light on you that light will hit you and
pop you into another location so i'm
smaller than the photon then what the
your whatever your your capacity to move
to a different state of existence that
the energy that that is required to make
that happen correct
energy the same as the energy of the
light that's hitting you gotcha so you
hit me
with in order
in order to see you
right and then you pop somewhere else
and i say where'd you go right what are
you doing so am i there am i not there
well we'll never really know
because you're hitting me with something
that makes me not there once you're
exposing me to it correct and and since
it happens on the moment you're exposed
not the moment i see you right i will
never know what you were doing exactly
okay if you're small enough for that
light energy to to affect you in that
way so that's why we don't think about
this in everyday life because we're too
big for light to pop us into other
states of existence exactly but
particles electrons atoms nuke all of
this it happens all the time and this
was a very disturbing discovery in the
1920s we're in the centennial decade of
the discovery of quantum physics in the
1920s because you discover this i want
to see what you're doing oh my gosh
you're not going to let me see what
you're doing
because the light i shine on you in
order to see it is so so it's really uh
it's not so much an observer effect it's
a measurement effect exactly okay get
the human brain out it's just the device
to measure you you you can't know it
okay right
so
so
let's get on to so it has nothing to do
with consciousness so let's get on to
schrodinger's cat by the way it's from
an era where people spoke lightly
of doing bad things to cats okay oh no
peter
you know yeah but peter wasn't around so
so i'm a little disturbed that they
picked cats right they could have picked
dogs they could have put worms but cats
are lovable and they'll fit in a box
right um and so
because cat house cats don't come as
large as house dogs do
just think that through
right
can you imagine yeah a box for a dog is
called your living room
right so
here's what happens you say to yourself
um you put a cat in a box
and if the cat is a quantum cat
with two states
states of existence it's either dead or
alive
while it's in the box
you have no idea which it is
and so the way we describe this in
quantum physics if you do the
experiments okay
so some percentage of the time you open
the box the cat will be alive others the
cat will be dead and so you
what we say is that the the cat's
existence
is a superposition of being dead and
being alive
i gotcha it's a superposition of those
two states because it's in the box it's
in the box and you're not looking at it
and you're not looking at it and that's
why the superposition exists correct and
it's a quantum cat not a microscope it's
not a it's not a it's not maru the
internet cat
that people love to see jump out of a
box okay all right it's a hypothetical
quantum cat by the way do you know cats
on the internet uh
took a steep rise the same year the cats
on broadway closed
the music really yes check your data on
that that is a weird little so we need
somebody we need somebody to investigate
that because where did those cats go is
what
so it was like 1990 you know early
internet you know uh and cats closes on
broadway and so i think people needed
their cat fix and they landed on the
internet but anyhow so here we go now
the superposition the details of that
experiment are
a more intricate thing than what i'm
describing to you because what they
wanted was to have like a
something that's radioactive that would
decay and then that would then trigger a
gate that would open the box you know
it's a little more rube goldbergian than
what i'm describing
but
just to be clear if you don't look in
the box you do not know if the cat is
alive or dead so the schrodinger's cat
is you're talking about something that
you don't know about
until you actually investigate it and
then you'll end up the movie seven
i didn't see that that was a movie that
came out many years ago with morgan
freeman and the beautiful man i forget
his name oh god he's uh he did 12
monkeys he's done uh thelma and louise
what's his name brad pitt thank you brad
pitt of course brad pitt so
brad pitt is
stalking a serial killer who is looking
who is using the seven deadly sins to
kill people long story short the last
murder
he puts the head of someone in the box
and brad pitt wants to know what's in
the box
and morgan freeman says don't look in
the box there's no reason for you to
look in this box and brad pitt goes
what's in the box because he knows that
it's his wife's head
that is completely morbid like what what
i don't know but it's perfect it should
be called schrodinger's cat it should be
called brad piff's white's wife's head
and
chuck that is the most morbid analogy to
this example i have ever heard oh oh
cause a dead cat is perfectly fine oh no
okay
so
so this actually
in a way applies to quantum computing
which you might have heard snippets
about or at least bits of headlines that
are uh making the news so if you think
of regular computing is like a zeros and
ones bits right and all calculations are
done in this way well
quantum computing
the i a bit a quantum bit
otherwise known as a qubit
can be either a zero or a one
or anything in between okay it could be
eighty percent one twenty percent zero
fifty fifty eighty percent zero twenty
percent one or anything on that
continuum
and so
so the qubit has more computational
versatility than a regular bit that can
only be
either a zero or a one
and and the and the when i say you can
be anywhere between a zero or one
statistically
you can
have
that bit represent eighty 80 ones 20
zeros uh 50 it can be any combination of
those two in the service of the
programming that you're introducing to
the computer
so all of that schrodinger's cat your
dead wife's head in a box right from
this morbid movie that now i'm never
going to see um
you were so excited about it too because
it's so much better than schroedinger's
cat okay it actually represents
something that is consequential
that you know i mean
never mind it doesn't really make a
difference
[Music]
it's i mean it doesn't make any
difference once you're in the quantum it
doesn't make a difference but it's just
a much cooler reference right right
because it's not a quantum head it's not
a quantum head so it doesn't make a
difference you know once you're in the
quantum it's not a it's not a cat it's a
quantum cat and it's not a head it's a
quantum head so
all right i see what you're saying it
was never really a cat to begin with
right it was a fictional quantum cat and
the same way it's a it's a quantum head
exactly
exactly
the world according to chuck
that's so funny you're like chuck uh go
have another bowl and get back to me
so chuck there it is that's like you
know schrodinger's cat 101. he could
have should call it schronger's coin is
it heads or tails right right exactly
it's just
is this is the quantum state only have
two possibilities right in that
description and so once you open the box
and and thereby gain access
to information that is otherwise hidden
from any observer or any uh device that
would make the measurement coin is
actually
the best representation
since if it's a superposition like we
said or like you said like i said right
please
look at me
look at me taking credit for quantum
discoveries
however that means it's always a
probability so probability correct it's
always a probability so that means
quantum coin is actually you came up
with the best one why why you got to do
that why you got to best me
i come up with a head in the box
and then you still got it you still got
to outdo me
really we
our fans with a head in a box version of
this i'm sorry
and just to be clear the the quantum
state doesn't have to be one or the
other right it depends on the atom and
or the circumstances but it can be any
number of different states that each
have a probability of being true exactly
and
in fact the wave function of the
particle
extends outside of the box
oh so the probability dropped rapidly
across the border of the box but it
still exists in a little bit outside the
box so
what's inside the box has a probability
of spontaneously disappearing from
inside the box and appearing outside the
box that's called tunneling
and it does that instantaneously like
faster than the speed of light another
spooky freaky thing in quantum physics
and that relates in part to quantum
entanglement because you can have two
different particles
whose wave functions interact
on a way that where you do something
that one particle the other one knows
about it instantly because their wave
functions communicate this is quantum
101 it's like fun parts of quantum that
is
crazy so we should do a lot of these
about quantum physics this was like an
overview i could spend a whole explainer
on each one of these things because this
is the decade in the 1920s was a
watershed decade in physics where hubble
discovers that we that the milky way is
not the only galaxy there are other
island universes they were called um in
andromeda is another galaxy containing
400 billion stars and
four year three years later in
1929 he discovered that the universe is
expanding and we apply einstein's
relativity to show that we've got
possibly a big bang which would later
would make 50 years before we had the
supporting data and
most of what we now know understand and
love about quantum physics was
discovered in the 1920s and we knew all
of that before the neutron was
discovered and before texas instrument
actually made a calculator
uh yeah
[Laughter]
and why
is that
because that means these guys had to
work that math oh i should just say
okay before anybody made a calculator
right right exactly
uh exactly by the way i had a friend who
had the very first texas instrument
scientific calculator and he knew it was
the first because it didn't even have a
model number on it wow it predated model
it would ultimately become the ti-35
but we i remember we all crowded around
it staring at it it was one of those
moments that you never forget okay i
just love the visual of a bunch of nerds
cradling around
and then you know you think they're
looking at a magazine or something and
then you part the ways and they're all
around a calculator like whoa
look at that can you believe this thing
welcome to the
geek verse the cosine do the cosine
again
now i'm a tangent man myself
[Laughter]
so i chuck we got to call it quits there
all right we ran over the clock on this
one
but quantum physics deserved a few extra
minutes we gave it i think absolutely
all right all right till next time this
has been a star talk explainer just for
you
neil degrasse tyson keep looking up
[Music]